cette secte fondée par un américain dans
les années 70 se disent croyantes et
entendent appliquer le précepte de la
bible aime ton prochain mail applique à
la lettre la bible a bon dos voilà une
cassette vidéo réalisée et diffusée dans
la secte des enfants de dieu
une fillette se déshabille devant la
caméra pour exciter le gourou elle a 10
ans samuel et daniel ont été membres des
enfants de dieu pendant longtemps
aujourd'hui ils sont sortis du groupe et
dénoncé pratiques
il parle de prostitution d'inceste
d'abus sexuels sur les enfants
documentation et cassettes vidéo de la
secte à l'appui x7 écrit dans leur livre
elle doit se déshabiller et ensuite
donner de l'amour c'est à dire avoir des
relations sexuelles avec les membres du
groupe le fondateur du mouvement c'est
lui david bergues
il a aujourd'hui 80 ans il vit dans la
clandestinité peut-être au japon début
des années 70 c'est la mode hippie sur
cette plage sur la côte est des états
unis
il crée son mouvement religieux fondé
sur l'amour pour lui la bible doit être
prise au sens littéral aimer son
prochain c'est faire l'amour avec son
prochain
sarah aussi s'est déshabillée pour david
bergues
elle est née dans la secte a vécu
plusieurs années en france dans une
communauté où elle dit avoir été violée
à l'âge de 12 ans aujourd'hui elle
préfère garder l'anonymat
ce que je voyais tous les autres filles
qui avaient mon âge qui dormait avec des
hommes et parler à tout le monde et tout
le monde y est il est que c'était bien
il y a quelques semaines nous avons
rencontré dans une communauté
les porte-parole de la secte en france
il en nier l'existence de relations
sexuelles entre adultes et enfants parce
que c'était autorisé un moment
encourager est-ce que ça l'est encore
jamais jamais pour les 10000 membres de
la secte david berg a prévu la fin du
monde pour très bientôt
et quand viendra l'apocalypse dit il
seuls survivront
les enfants de dieu